and it comes to the cleavage girls how
much I got too much cleavage out today
or not enough welcome back to glamour UK
I'm backstage a Victoria's Secret Show
Exhibit A and I'm going to be bringing
you all the best models all the top tips
on how you can come an angel at home
your South get those halos ready how I
can become a Victoria's Secret Angel
myself inside okay I feel like I
couldn't say as comfortable with myself
as I was the first time if I was gonna
look at myself in the marriage before I
hit the runway what Compton's mantra
should I tell myself
you are gorgeous what are your top tips
for hair flipping like a Victoria's
Secret Angels would you say is it more
shooting from the hair anymore about the
fast yeah it's about that I'm Laura the
calm cool and collected
I love it and if I start to keep boy in
the crowd when I was walking the runway
do you know if I saw it keep going the
crowd at probably start sweating are you
more of an angel or a devil in real life
oh hello see you don't and also we can't
not talk about that major
kardashian-jenner Victoria's Secret's
moment they could have been hoody Pete's
got the most angel-like qualities out of
all of them all of them all together
yeah I was gonna get a last-minute call
to be a Victoria's Secret Angel yes
fingers crossed cool me hands what
topics would you get me yes I love we
should bring this make this happen
I'm into it every year I I honestly try
to learn so I don't know if I'm like the
best to give you advice I just think
it's about like feeling all the love and
good energy and support that we know
that our friends and these girls have
for us and to try to just like embrace
that and really feel loved and excited
as important
so feel the love feel the love all
yourself love for everyone in the world
what top tasty kid means like you know
giving him the eye just stare them down
and make him really hope I'm just
kidding I think like maybe like the
hard-to-get thing yeah you know like
like one look and like a smile but then
like you know I have other plans I can
do whatever I want today
I mean place I bet you all the Queen of
Pop - gasps yeah in the beginning for
you what kind of light half my pigment
techniques could you teach okay first
what I do is I go down and I like
getting the roots in my hair so it gets
like some nice volume and then I flip my
sides the less you have to like get your
side first that's a good important
what's the biggest thing most extreme
excuse you he's the cow things the chair
I've never really like been just like a
gym goers like I always like play
volleyball or ride horses or like box so
I feel like you don't need any excuse I
never like have an excuse like if it's
not a day that I want to work out then I
honestly am like I accept myself for
that
I go on a nice walk I pick some flowers
I go my garden I mix it I cook something
like you don't have to put so much
pressure on yourself and I think that
when you do things that you have fun
doing and you let it be a natural part
of your life and it's always positive
you